greetings and Welcome to our series
about bigquery cost optimization
our first part in the series is talking
about how you can optimize your billing
using bigquery compute and essentially
that means optimizing how are you
getting billed for queries that you're
running
let's start with an overview of the
bigquery architecture just so we're all
on the same page about the different
methods that are available for
optimization
bigquery is a fully separated storage
and compute data warehouse and lake
house this means that you only pay for
the storage as you store data and the
compute as you analyze data we'll be
focusing on compute optimization today
the common unit of compute measurement
in bigquery is called a slot you can
think of a slot as a set of CPU memory
and disk that is assigned to run a query
a group of slots typically work together
to complete a query slots can be
assigned to a query dynamically meaning
that by query stage a query may be
allocated more or fewer slots based on
the compute needs of the query so
bigquery dynamically allocates these
across your queries and Google Cloud
projects for query execution
it's important also to note that this
means that bigquery can automatically
horizontally and vertically scale for
any query or concurrency based on
different queries required
compute can be purchased in two ways in
bigquery using on demand where you're
charged for the byte scanned as a part
of the query and with additions where
you pay for the slot capacity used by
your queries
choosing the method that you want comes
down to how much data you typically use
what features you need in order to
complete your queries and what other
business critical things you need based
on your organization requirements
it's important to note you can mix and
match your building here giving you the
ultimate flexibility the billing method
is assigned at the project level you
could have multiple projects with
different billing methods including
additions
and the on-demand mode one method that
you have to control your total spend is
by setting custom quotas for the maximum
amount of bytes processed this means
that you'll limit the number of bytes
that a user or across a project can
actually be consumed during a day and
helps you to limit things like runaway
queries where a user may have
accidentally selected something where
there's far more data than they actually
are allowed to process or should be
processing as a part of the query
and the additions model the first lever
that you have is to choose the type of
addition that you would like to use to
process your data
check the feature list to see which
Edition works best for you and then you
can choose based on the type of slots
what you'd like to purchase
with both standard and Enterprise and
Enterprise Plus you can set a maximum
level of the number of slots that you'd
like to scale up to in Enterprise and
Enterprise Plus you can also pick a
number of Baseline slots which are slots
that you will always have guaranteed
these ones can also be purchased
Baseline slots can be purchased at a
commitment based on the duration of how
long you'd like to have the slots for
let's look at a simple example here of
using multiple projects with a single
reservation
you can see here that we have three
projects and we have a baseline of 400
slots which means that we're guaranteed
400 slots across our projects
we can see here that we have our queries
start to scale up in both Project A and
B so we're incrementally purchasing an
additional 400 slots from our Baseline
but only for the time that the queries
actually need them and we're dynamically
scaling further up to a thousand slots
total 600 Slots of which are Auto
scaling to meet our actual query demand
is Project C comes becomes available
once the query perform or the query
demand goes down we can see that because
there's now only 300 slots required for
project C that we can actually release
the reservations for the additional
slots that we had for the auto scaler
and as a result of it now we're back
just using our Baseline slots what we've
been able to do here is both
horizontally and vertically Auto scale
and only pay for the capacity when we
need it
we hope this is an helpful overview for
you to understand how you can optimize
your query compute using bigquery and
then leveraging different components to
optimize your spend while getting the
best performance thanks for your time
and Happy querying